(light music)
- We take this bracket out,
get a better...
The microphone on this side.
- Yeah.
- Almost 300 million of
these were sold in 2021
and AirPods are by far the most popular.
They made up about a third
of all earbuds shipped
around the world last year.
But unlike an iPhone or a Mac,
if one of these starts to have an issue,
Apple might replace it,
but it won't repair them
or help you do it yourself.
Why is that?
To find out, we're gonna
take a look inside an AirPod
and ask technicians how
repairable they actually are.
Yeah, so tell me a little bit
about what you do at iFixit.
- Our job at iFixit is to
assess the repairability
of electronic and consumer devices.
Anything that comes
across our teardown table,
we break apart to see
how repairable it is.
- How hard is it to get into these things?
- If you want to take this
apart, non-destructively,
to replace the batteries,
as far as I know, that's impossible.
- So we're starting by melting the glue.
I'm using this
to melt the glue?
- Yep.
- God, this feels so wrong.
(heat gun whirs)
- Oh, it's separating. There you go.
Yeah. Let's take a break here.
- Oh no. Okay.
- One of the reasons they use glue
is because, , it's a very effective way
of preventing sweat and
moisture from getting inside.
The question is, is it worth the cost?
- We can replace the battery now.
(both chuckle)
- The AirPod's not gonna work anymore,
but you could replace the battery.
Okay.
There you go.
- I got it.
- You got it.
- Boom.
- Nice. All right.
- I think our best bet is
just to use the sonic knife
and go right through.
(knife squeaking)
- Okay. That definitely went through.
Oh, okay. We got it.
Do you think Apple could
put this thing together?
- They won't service these things.
I would love to be proven wrong.
I would love for Apple to say,
"Actually, yeah we can get
into these and fix these."
- [Host] So what exactly
happens to AirPods
after they have issues?
- Well, Apple says it
will replace your AirPod
and send the previous one
to a best-in-class recycler
for responsible handling.
Apple doesn't provide
repair manuals for AirPods
the way it does for some iPhones and Macs.
That makes it that much more difficult
for third-party technicians
to make repairs.
And like we saw earlier,
since these are so difficult to get into,
repairing them probably isn't
the most practical option.
When it comes to repairability,
iFixit rated the original AirPods Pro
a definitive zero out of 10
and says it's one of the most unrepairable
among its competitors.
So why does that matter?
Well, Apple shipped more
than 90 million earbuds
in 2022 alone.
Within a couple of years,
a lot of those AirPods
will end up being recycled
or tossed in the trash
because of this part right here.
Experts say the batteries
used in Bluetooth earbuds
only last about 18 months
before they start to have problems.
Let's take a look at this graph.
While not focused specifically on AirPods,
it generally shows how
lithium ion batteries age.
The x-axis shows how many
times the battery is cycled
or charged and discharged.
The y-axis shows how much
the battery can store
compared to its initial max.
Notice that around 350 cycles,
things really drop off.
The lead researcher told
me that drop in the graph
is the reason your device
can work fine one day
and have performance issues
and less battery life the next.
Apple acknowledges that
rechargeable batteries
have a limited lifespan.
It says how long they last
depends on how often you charge them.
Eventually, performance issues
might send you back to the
Apple store for a new pair
or those old earbuds
may end up in a drawer,
the garbage or the recycling bin.
So can AirPods be repaired?
- Yes.
If you want, you can try at home,
although I don't recommend.
It's so tedious.
- It may be hard, but that
doesn't mean it's impossible.
Swap Club will send you a
refurbished pair of AirPods
and try to repair your old ones.
The startup developed a semi-automated way
to fix a variety of AirPod issues.
- If you do it yourself,
it's probably gonna take
you an hour (chuckles).
And the automation allows
us to really scale this.
- According to Swap club,
there's just one small problem.
- In terms of repairability,
we see them just getting
tighter and tighter
and we have to continue
to change our process
to accommodate that with each generation.
- There's a ton of tech
packed into this tiny thing,
and Apple adds more each year.
The new H2 chip adds longer battery life.
There's also a new skin detection sensor.
And it has a new swipe interface
and improved microphones
for clearer calls.
- In the same generation,
we've noticed some AirPods
have slight differences.
The thing that we all love
the most about AirPods,
which is their tight,
small, compact design,
is a thing that actually
makes it most difficult
for them to be repaired.
- Apple is working within some guardrails.
It can only increase the size so much
if you want earbuds that
fit snugly in your ears.
And Apple doesn't wanna make products
that are too complicated or
look too difficult to use.
- So it's not just the manufacturers.
We can't just blame the manufacturers
for creating the device.
Consumers are driving the demand for it.
- So after about two hours of work,
I only managed to tear down one AirPod
and obviously that thing's
never gonna work again.
To be clear, repairability
isn't just an Apple issue.
All rechargeable batteries
will die eventually.
And it's a pretty common practice
to hold things together with glue.
But the thing is, not all
are as hard to repair.
(light music fades)